foreign
it's December 6 2022 we're in active
bookstream number
001.01
a numbering convention that will be
explained soon
it's a discussion on the book governing
continuous transformation by vijayan
kazri and I'll pass the blue
hi everyone I guess that's my job is to
explain the uh bookstream numbering so
this is our first book stream that's why
it's bookstream001 and this is our first
dot zero contextualization video for
this bookstream series so each week we
will present a chapter ish a chapter or
so of the book and then periodically we
will get together for the zero zero one
dot one zero zero one dot two and so
forth those discussion sections so if
you want to participate either in a
contextualization video or in a
discussion video please get in touch
with us and we would love to have you
um on the stream and I'm blue I've been
here before so hopefully you've seen me
before and know me by now and I'm an
independent researcher in New Mexico and
I will pass it off to Tyler first time
appearance I think in the active
inference Institute so Tyler do you want
to introduce yourself yeah cool thanks
for having me this is my first time here
to actually inference so I have a an
unusual background actually don't come
from in an academic background at all a
lot of it's been about applied
governance so I actually started as a
strategy consultant working in major
corporations more recently it's gotten
more to Dow governance I currently lead
product and protocol design for the 4K
protocol it's a project that is
connecting the physical world to the
on-chain world and I'm also a
contributor at medigov where I think
about how we can model these abstract
formalisms about governance in a real
world setting and so a lot of times when
I think about Dow governance but most
recently it's been thinking about active
inference and implicit implications for
real world settings
foreign
so we are a participatory online lab
that is communicating learning and
practicing applied active inference
these are all of our media links
um and we will be recording And
archiving this live stream for future
reference
um everyone is welcome and hopefully we
will be following good etiquette for
live streams and not arguing or talking
over each other for the duration of the
book streams
um
okay so this is our first book stream
um our goal is to learn and discuss this
textbook governing continuous
transformation reframing the strategy
governance conversation it's a 2022 book
by Bijan kesri and this video like
always is just an introduction to some
of the ideas not a review or a final
word at all so we will just go through
here
um the sections of this book stream
we're going to do the book map and the
road map some keywords the preface part
one and chapter one will be covered in
today's video and in the coming weeks we
will be continuing to discuss this so
get in touch if you want to partake in
these conversations
um so I guess we introduced ourselves
briefly
um oh backwards so if either you guys
want to maybe mention something you're
excited about or that you liked or
remembered from the book from these
first sessions
um otherwise we can go on to discover it
I think we have a lot of material Tyler
what are you most excited about
yeah I mean I think for me like
especially being in like real world
organizations non-profits a lot of times
we think of like uncertainty as
something that could be wished away or
something that we're incrementally going
to solve like oh if we only were
collecting like more information we
would be in a better spot or I don't
think we had more capabilities this we
wouldn't have this problem
um but a lot of times we kind of get
very anxious about that uncertainty
rather than we're an active inference
and free energy governance that
uncertainty is placed at the center and
it's something you could actually take
ownership over but also be a source of
you know creative uh growth and so I
think that's really exciting and
inspirational and yeah really excited to
be here today
cool I'm excited too to unify some of
the concepts of active inference with
governance which I know a little bit
about but not very much and now that
we're like formalizing our structure as
an Institutional entity in the active
inference Institute
um I'm excited to learn more about
governance and how things should work
um okay so this book has four parts so
we're here well we're not even in part
one yet but we're going to to go over to
the beginning of part one today so part
one is reframing the strategy governance
conversation part two is about free
energy governance and part three is a
conclusion for the book and then there
are some interviews in part four along
with acknowledgments and an epilogue and
this is from the bookmap software so
this is like our road map for a book um
but this bookmap software is used in in
trading so if you guys have never seen
it that's what these graphs are from so
when I think about bookmap I always
think about that uh okay so our roadmap
for today so we're going to get into the
preface there are no section headings so
we just kind of chunked out like what
makes sense
um in terms of of the text and how it
reads so we're going to go over a
summary of the fep how to ground firms
in the framework of active inference
strategy governance model models versus
meta governance the triplet structure of
free energy governance and then realists
and anti-realists in management science
and then just a brief intro to part one
and then chapter one which is pretty
short thinking born of curiosity revolt
and change
um so here's like a huge list of
pre-words of pre-words of keywords that
we're going to get into today and I
think Tyler is going to start us off
um in we're in section one in the
preface in the summary of the free
energy principle Tyler's gonna start us
off talking about the fep
Tyler and mute
sorry uh so the pre-energy principle or
fep as we're going to be calling it uh
this is John's definition that he gives
in the preface so the fep uh is a
mathematical formulation that explains
from first principles to characteristics
of biological systems that are able to
resist Decay and persist over time it
rests on the idea that all biological
systems instantiate a hierarchical
generative model of the world that
personally minimizes its internal
entropy by minimizing free energy
blew anything you'd want to add there
no I think um it's best like we could
take a deep dive into the fvp there are
many live streams where that's done so
if you want to learn more about the free
energy principle I would just refer out
to other live streams it's best here to
take what Bijan presents the aspect that
he's using and go forward from there
cool and I think uh similarly we'll do a
similar cursory treatment of Markov
blankets uh and so markup blankets so we
could think about it is that it's a
statistical formulation for defining the
internal versus the external so the
definition that he gives is Marco
blankets establish a conditional
Independence between internal and
external states that renders the inside
open to the renders the inside open to
the outside but only in a conditional
sense so I.E the internal states only
see the external States through the veil
of the Marco Blanca again huge topic
we're not going to go super into it
unless you're gonna add anything blue no
it's great um and and there are many
many live streams like really if you
want to get into it probably the
emperor's new Markov blankets is maybe
where we undertake like a very thorough
um discussion of the Markov blanket if
you want more information there
all right so grounding firms in the
framework of active inference
so here's a claim from the book learning
to actively infer will determine the
firm's competitive advantage and
survival in a discontinuous and
distributed world the more fluid the
boundaries between firm and Eco Niche
the more important the definition of
what constitutes a system and how
non-discipitative markovian boundaries
preserve the firm's Integrity I.E belief
systems our interest is Shifting away
from pursuing deterministic truth
through clever analysis towards
designing entailing a generative
self-organizing model that empowers the
firm to master the shifting conditional
independencies between the known and
unknown and what lies within and Beyond
its control whoa so there's a lot there
so I think these next keyword slides
hopefully will unpack it a little bit
uh active inference
um which we've seen many times in the
active inference Institute is a process
Theory grounded in the free energy
principle that explains Behavior
perception planning and action in terms
of probabilistic inference
um Fijian doesn't yet mention active
inference but he talks about learning to
actively infer which I'm going to
actively infer means active inference
and here we see this classic action
perception Loop where we have internal
States and external States separated by
a Markov blanket or a non-disaptive
markovian boundary and we have sensory
input and action and these are the ways
in which an agent can interact with this
world do either you guys have anything
to add here
Daniel
um in that framing I found it really
interesting when there's increased
fluidity or fuzziness or blurriness of
the engagement of the firm with the
niche or the context or the community in
those cases it's like more important to
have a uncertainty oriented definition
of what the thing is and that is what
confronts every organization today
yeah interesting
um okay so he talked a little bit about
shifting away from deterministic truth
and so like I I like Googled because I'm
a truth a truth person I'm weird about
truth if you've ever like listened to me
talk about it before so deterministic
truth is like the truth
um and I I liked this paper like I just
Googled it like what do people talk
about what is deterministic truth
um and I I found this paper approaching
determinist deterministic and
probabilistic Truth a unified account
and and in this paper it's a 2021 paper
so pretty new
um in this paper they talked about the
truth itself like the truth being either
deterministic like I think about that
like hitting a bullseye like the truth
is the number seven
and then probabilistic truth is more
like a probability distribution around
that truth like hitting seven plus or
minus the standard deviation or like a
probability density right
um and this paper talked about like
deterministic and probabilistic Truth
like that the truth is one of those
things and then also there are ways to
approach it like you're approaching your
search of the truth in either a
deterministic or probabilistic way so I
thought that this was an interesting
read and kind of if you are interested
in delving deeper into like
deterministic deterministic versus
probabilistic and these theories and um
approaches and and Truth likeness I
thought this was a cool um read
yeah I think one thing oh sorry no the
whole thing to add there is just I think
like our personal ideas about what truth
are like whether it's terministic versus
a probabilistic conception of Truth
really carry over onto the organization
level and so whatever kind of delusions
you have about your personal truth in
your personal life a lot of times they
view the organization as like the CEO
abuse the organization as an extension
of their own self and so their own world
view gets carried over and you know
strapped on to the organization of the
world view
um and so it's really interesting that
you could kind of frame these like
philosophical ideas about truth that are
often applied at an individual level and
then kind of like scale that up into an
organization
yeah very cool
um and we see that in this um this
generative self-organizing model again
this is kind of like it was cool to just
search up what is a self-organizing
model
um and and we see generative Model A lot
um we don't really see self-organizing
model we see generative model in terms
of self-organization but a generative
self-organizing model like what is this
really
um um and so just this is just from this
um Stanford
machine learning cheat sheet supervised
learning cheat sheet so here it says
discriminative models divide the data
space into classes by learning the
boundaries and this is like the
different neural networks whereas
generative models understand how the
data is embedded into the space like an
auto encoder or boltzmann machine or
self-organizing Maps so this is like a
self-organizing model and you can really
see here like this is the like a
decision boundary on the left in the
discriminative model and like either
it's a cat or a dog right and on the
right it's there's a generative model
like it's a cat with some degree of
certainty or it's a dog with some degree
of of certainty and so you see these
like probability distributions like
probably it's a cat but then there's
like some fuzzy like if your data point
lands like a little bit in the red or a
little bit in the blue like then then it
might be a cat or it might be a dog
maybe we don't have enough information
to tell
um so I thought that this was a cool
like replication of the probabilistic
truth versus deterministic truth like
either you're looking for cat or dog or
you're looking for with what probability
is this a cat or a dog
um do you guys have anything to add here
cool okay so this is moving on out of
this claim into the next claim
um The Firm is envisioned as an inactive
sophisticated and resource dependent
inference machine in form of a
generative learning model essentially it
is a statistical model linking in
circular causality action perception
firm resources and the unknown external
world and I just put this active
inference Loop up here again so you have
like the firm and the world the firm
would be the agent and then you have the
resources of the firm which would be
like the internal States and then the
external world
which is everything that's not the firm
um and I highlighted these terms
inactive and sophisticated because
there's a lot to unpack here
um and I think it's kind of in the
textbook maybe like just you can say the
words but unless you like open them up
and look what they mean inside look
inside of them like you don't have any
idea the kind of depth that goes behind
these things
so
um do you guys have anything to add
there on that okay
um inactivism is a position in cognitive
science that argues that cognition
arises through a dynamic interaction
between an acting organism and its
environment and so these are the four
e's of uh cognitive science and so or
cognition and they're embodied and
active extended and in cultured so
cognition is grounded in our senses and
concrete experience that's embodied
enacted means it's goal directed action
in the real world
um
extended is cognitive systems include
the tools the devices the people around
us our smartphone these kinds of things
and embedded or that's kind of what we
always refer to as in cultured but I
think that they kind of mean the same
thing so this is cognition is woven into
culture and learning is done in a social
context so these are the the embodied So
when you say the firm is inactive
um yeah that that's it it's good for
goal directed it's doing goal directed
action in the real world and active
and sophisticated or do you guys have
anything to add there on the 40s okay
sophisticated is from this paper I
believe a sophisticated inference by
Kristen and colleagues and we've done
sophisticated affective inference I
think on a live stream but I don't think
we've ever done sophisticated inference
but the affective inference is
um like a later paper and covers this
one a lot so sophisticated inference is
really like in deep time right so here
I'll just read this the figure caption
so I have this like decision tree model
a picture from the paper and it says
this schematic summarizes the
accumulation of expected free energy
over paths and trajectories into the
future this can be construed as a deep
tree search where the tree branches of
reliable actions at each point point in
time and the likely outcomes consequent
upon each action so this is one two
three four time steps here and going off
so this is like a trajectory the path of
least action uh so we talk about you
know the way that
a system can decide and go forward in in
space
so that's what's meant by sophisticated
I think
oh Daniel
yeah
the purpose of introducing these terms
from cognitive sciences and Neuroscience
like the 4E cognition and of this type
of model it's not a novel idea to make a
decision tree that's how for example
early chess playing artificial
intelligence's work
it's the way that the expected free
energy can be calculated across these
different Paths of consideration with
respect to a generative model
that are allowing new ways of thinking
about these kinds of deep time and
nested strategic questions
um okay
so temporal thickness and counterfactual
depths here in this claim Bijan says the
proposal on offer here is that the Mind
comes into being when self-evidencing
has a temporal thickness models can be
thicker and thinner deeper or shallower
depending on how far forward they
predict or counterfactual depth how far
back they post it that is whether they
can capture how things might have ended
up if they had acted differently there
is no real reason for Minds to exist
they appear to do so simply because
existence itself is the endpoint of a
process of reasoning Consciousness I'd
contend is nothing grander than
inference about my future and in this
this is from bhajan's book but he's
quoting friston 2017 paper
um so that temporal thickness goes back
to this sophistication right which is
what why like so here you can see how
how far back you can post it like if I
had done something differently what
could have happened
um this counterfactual reasoning and
then and prediction going forward into
the future
okay going on to strategy governance
models versus meta governance
all right so I'm kind of out of my uh
Comforts I'm here so I might call in
Tyler to help me out a little bit
um but Bijan says the common
understanding underlying entrenched
strategy governance models rather
erroneously has been that action is a
consequence of perception and therefore
strategy must be environment driven so I
look up strategy governance model and it
gave me like some figures and this is
one of them and it appears to be um
pretty linear but but there's not a lot
of feedback happening with the external
environment like there's Vision the
strategy a road map design and then
insights come forward to the design and
back to the division and then there's
like a performance review so I don't
know Tyler do you want to give any
additional comments here on this yeah I
mean I think something that could be
potentially confusing for people who are
maybe not coming from an academic
background is that like a lot of times
what Business Leaders are thinking about
how they're going to plan for the action
that their organizations to take what
the strategy looks like you know they're
getting data right and they're having
feedback from the bottom levels of the
organization feedback to the top levels
right and so that they're taking
information they're creating a
perception of that and then they're
creating a strategy based on that that
kind of in a linear fashion the
organization executes and at some point
they reflect back and be like hey did
this work or not what do we do with our
new information right but really what
they're not realizing in the process of
that is like in that linear flow they're
not recognizing how they're constraining
the perceptions and actions of their
organization in a top-down fashion and
allowing and allowing bottom-up
information to change how information
and actions can be changed in the future
so like that kind of cyclical nature
really to understand it's really more
conceived in this linear way of like hey
we're going to collect as much
information as we can our information is
going to be imperfect but we're going to
get better over time
rather than like hey fundamentally our
actions and perceptions are constrained
by the actions we're taking right now so
it's like just a different model for
thinking but it's a lot more linear and
not doesn't have that cyclical causality
uh baked into it
cool and I think about here like
um it seems like it's very like um
sequential like one after another after
another after another whereas like the
active inference kind of method like you
have to sometimes act in order to
perceive right like the if you want to
know whether like the surface is rough
or smooth you have to move over the
surface with your finger to determine if
it's rough or smooth so it's action and
perception that are happening
simultaneously and I think that that
that is the shift that Bijan is calling
for
um as he says
yeah and I think just to add in that
like a little bit is that I think a lot
of times Business Leaders conceive of
like reality as like independently
existing out there and it's just like a
limitation of their tools and resources
to understand reality rather than like
the nature of perception itself of being
able to understand reality and so I
think that's really like the fundamental
difference and a lot of times people
don't realize that that's even like
relevant at all uh and so that's why
this is fun to talk about
that's for sure why like what is
deterministic truth like where is that
reality
um and it all kind of links together
um so Jean goes on to say in fact action
upon the firm's Eco Niche akin to
pointing the light torch in the dark
determines perception inference is
inactive the generative model itself
never encodes anything it just expresses
the circular causality among all four
states the generative model hence is a
model of the firm's econish if not it is
no good regulator and consequently The
Firm will rather sooner than later
dissipate in the face of entropic forces
um and so I included here A different
kind of strategy governance model that's
like the Lean Startup model that's like
a little bit more action and perception
happening in like a more simultaneous
way I don't know if you want to add
anything here Tyler
yeah I think um a lot of the way we talk
about like Lean Startup model of really
the least our model is basically like
you don't necessarily know what people
want and also it's not that you're
discovering what people want is that
you're putting ideas out there and
finding how people respond respond to
them uh and so it's basically truth is
something that you create you can create
a new state of the world rather than
like uncovering it so it's kind of like
a method for uncovering something that's
going to work and a lot of times it's
kind of done how can like very like
fluffy and also just like experiential
terms of like hey this works we've done
this we built this company this way but
what's interesting about active
inferences that can take that very like
fluffy wispy framework and apply that
into a more rigorous context uh so yeah
like a lot of these ideas that we're
talking about now like they're not
necessarily like new and like especially
like startup world but there hasn't been
great language for talking about it
cool
all right so here's another claim
therefore the firm's true governance
challenge is a matter of meta governing
its generative model as an enacted
sophisticated and resource-dependent
belief system exercising the entire
organization quote the body itself in
Contours we should now start seeing a
model emerging that underwrites a form
of Auto autopoiesis I.E
self-organization effectively it is all
about casting inferences optimization
mathematically by way of gradient
descent starting with two essential
constituents first a hyper prior which
is the firm's resistance to entropy in
order to persist and two epistemic
foraging and hypothesis testing I.E
acting upon the Eco Niche to generate
belief evidencing data
um do you guys have any comments here do
you want to delve into this a little
more Daniel
yeah one interesting uh usage of a term
there is that the firm's true governance
challenge is meta governance and that's
a term that is used differently or
compatibly but with a different focus in
medigov and so just to kind of Flesh
that out here meta governance is being
used in the sense of metacognition like
self-reflection memory anticipation
attention planning all of these
individual level cognitive and
metacognitive processes that we model in
active inference
often medicov in another sense is meant
like social cognition like relationships
amongst organizations or amongst teams
so like within a team you have their own
governance structure then also there's
teams of teams and that's a meta
governance structure with respect to the
team
and then that's very interesting because
the two times that we've seen nested
models nested generative models inactive
inference are the metacognition models
and then the ecosystem nested models so
it really brings Integrity between
thinking about what happens like within
and across groups
cool thank you
um okay so hyper prior
um in Bayesian statistics a high
proprietor is a prior Distribution on a
hyper parameter that is on a parameter
of a prior distribution as with the term
hyper parameter the use of hyper
is to distinguish it from a prior
distribution of a parameter of the model
for the underlying system
so like the hyper parameters influence
the prior here and like the hyper
parameters here influence the parameters
here and so it's it's backwards at least
one step in time
in this sophisticated format so there's
oh yeah this is a better diagnosis or
illustration the hyper prior goes to the
prior goes to the data so it's just in a
previous time step in some way
um anything to add here
all right
epistemic foraging I pulled this from
active inference and learning this this
quote
um it says inactive inference Behavior
has explorative epistemic and
exploitative pragmatic aspects that are
sensitive to ambiguity and risk
respectively where epistemic Ambu
ambiguity resolving Behavior enables
pragmatic reward seeking Behavior and
the subsequent emergence of habits
um and and I just wanted to kind of
point out here that that active
inference is kind of like has been
Illustrated as like a balance a way to
balance exploration and exploitation and
epistemic and pragmatic value
um and like in business is this like
knowledge and and money is that like
epistemic and pragmatic value like
knowledge of your customers your clients
so it's just trying to think of like how
this might um translate to that like
like money pragmatic values like more
research sources and you know like
epistemic value is like more knowledge
of your client base or or of of the
future maybe
um uncertainty production
and I could just give like a concrete
example of that because like it was
especially true in software engineering
where that is actually frame and
explicitly these terms and uh like
growth organizations so if you're on the
growth team you're like okay we can
either like turn up the dial on this
thing that's working we're like okay
like we know this flow is working this
wizard for this checkout flow is working
let's make it like 10 faster would be an
example of exploitation where like we
know that's going to work in some level
where acceleration could be something we
have like really no idea this is like a
shot in the dark let's figure out the
minimum amount of effort we can put out
to to uncover new territory and so like
this exact
trade-off is very much explicitly
thought of in a lot of tech
organizations
very cool thank you yeah so epistemic
foraging is like you know searching
around so like you know for for
epistemic seeking out um epistemic
value
um okay so moving on to the triplet
structure of free energy governance
uh Tyler this is for you I think
um so
you know Jean's frames like really
there's like a key question of your
energy governance when you're thinking
about your organization how do you
embody the academic emergency
organization
um and it's really about how you create
and update your generative model so that
the firm can survive and he presents
this framework of thinking about it and
he calls it the triplet structure of
re-energy governance there is structure
cognition and then capabilities so we'll
go through uh each of these in turn
all right structure
so oh sorry this is confusing B
that header is wrong just get to the
next slide
all right structure
um so this John writes that connectivity
emerges in flow and language bottom up
stimuli emanating from resource markets
such as clients Technologies suppliers
another are only as relevant and
meaningful to Resource configuration
asset allocation as clearly as top-down
predictions and prediction models
articulated communicated and above all
programmed to process bottom up incoming
signals
um so like we kind of touched on this
earlier but like a lot of times decision
making at organization is very linear
where like at the very top you're coming
up with a strategy and then like that's
executed in current at every rung of the
hierarchy and a lot of times like okrs
if you've ever heard of this it's like a
really good example of this it's like
objective key results where like there's
an objective that the top the
organization comes with and then like
the minions the next run have their sub
subsequent parts of that tree and it
kind of filters down to the rest of the
organization
um where sometimes what's not as clearly
articulated is about the
interconnections between different parts
of the hierarchy and how those different
parts of the stack uh have to relate to
each other so like a really good example
of this is that you know this is very
true in tech companies tech companies
collect a ton of data and none of that
data is like ever processed in a
meaningful way and so like a lot of
times you'll say like oh like we got
we're data driven company we collect all
this information but in reality like a
lot of information is trapped at the
bottom rungs of the organization it may
not have like the political ability or
also even the technical ability to
process that in a meaningful way and
bubble that up through the organization
and a lot of times there's a huge gap in
being able to actually process that
information and bubble it up
appropriately uh in a way that can
actually like crater the organization
and so this is like designing this in a
really thoughtful way is
much harder than it would seem and even
if you call yourself a data driven
organization there's a good chance
you're not processing data in a way that
can actually be generate new top-down
models later on so yeah anything to add
there where Virginia
all right let's go to the next one
cognition
all right so cognition Embraces the
environment as enacted through relations
and interactions constructed in our
brains environment is not objectively
accurate independently exists but is
revealed by a firm's actions and
perceptions that those firms that those
very actions generate in fact the
consequences of the firm's activity
construct it's equal niche
um and so we've already kind of touched
on some of the earlier slides But the A
lot of times these firms conceive of
external reality existing independently
of their own actions and perceptions and
then it's just like up to them to get
better tools and information
um to be able to like understand that
reality like understanding this fog of
war that they're like slowly uncovering
um
but they actually do real insights then
also the actions that they're able to
take so like to make this like a little
bit more concrete you can say like I
mean if you're not
this very much applies in a real Sense
on like a website where like if you're
not collecting information on views on
your page in a very basic level it's
really hard to like generate actual
information out of that right and so you
have to basically make a decision of
like this is the information we want to
gather this is what we care about and
that's going to structure the insights
you can glean in the future and like
what you can do with that information in
a similar way like if you're not putting
resources out for interacting with the
world like creating a new Department
that's maybe a little bit more
exploratory that's going to constrain
the actions you can take in the future
so all this is saying is that uh the
reality doesn't exist independently of
you it's something that you
actively perceive through your actions
and perceptions
down blue and add anything there is it
like actively perceived or actively
create
um actively sorry I actively create a
better way of saying it well or or both
I mean I think like you have to be um
either actively perceiving but but
um I don't know I think
it's it's a rare treat when someone
takes responsibility or even like a
company takes responsibility for
um the reality that they're creating
um and like we see this especially like
in tech companies like I don't know
Facebook and I mean like just like a lot
of the technology has been life-changing
and world changing so like they're
really actively creating reality Daniel
yeah this is uh interesting about the
revealing of the firm's generative model
through its actions and we've talked
about that four-fold partition with the
internal external States and then the
sense and action blanket States so the
firm has access to sense and internal
states to some extent
but the world or others have access to
one's actions and or
inference on their consequences in the
niche and so it's a way to talk about
what the entire action perception Loop
is with all of its different inward
facing and outward facing Dynamics
yeah to add a little more here too like
there's a lot of focus on around this
idea as well and like startup culture
and so I I'm a totally butcher there's
like a Steve Jobs Club totally butcher
about something around the lines of like
if you had done a marketing survey of
people before they made the iPod and
asked them how they want to listen to
music they wouldn't have told you that
they wanted an iPod they would have told
you something else that was conditioned
based on their previous experiences
products and so the idea is that you
just put something out in the world it's
a creative act and that you create
something in the world and then the
world responds to it
um and so there's like this big idea
especially in like Tech culture around
like reality is something that you will
into existence rather than
um discover independently
yeah it's interesting too to like think
about I mean especially you think about
Google Glass that came out like I don't
know 10 years ago or something now I'm
probably not that long ago but it's been
a little while and I think like now
there's like the re-release of like
Google Glass or some kind of similar
product like the world just wasn't ready
when the Google blast version came out
but but like we'll be ready soon we've
they've wielded into existence and it'll
be that way soon
all right capabilities the last one is
capabilities
um so the inferring firm is constantly
optimizing belief propagation as well as
updating beliefs uh sophistication that
process that process of optimizing
recognition densities is only as good as
the firm's General the world model so we
are no longer just interested in the
actions consequences per se uh about how
the actions consequences impact
ulterior beliefs
um so
another way of saying this is that the
firm has to actively balance you know
this exploiting for reverse
um exploring
and I think there's like a lot of again
folk wisdom and especially in Silicon
Valley culture around this trade-off
whereas like a lot of times we say hey
failure is good as long as you're
learning and integrating those those
insights
um and so
yeah it blew anything to add there
no good all right
um okay so realists and anti-realists in
management science
all right so here's a claim from Bijan
management science is equally divided
along not too dissimilar realists and
anti-realist fault lines it is best
captured by Carl week 1977 when he
states that environment is located in
the mind of the actor and is imposed by
him on experience in order to make that
experience more meaningful
it's seldom Dawns on organizational
theorists to look for environments
inside the heads rather than outside of
them indeed the rise of cognitive lens
in strategy management and governance
research has enriched our understanding
around improving the design of strategy
governance processes but has largely
remained constrained by the notion that
environment is something objective out
there waiting to be analyzed and adapted
to
um and in in this section uh Bijan talks
about Blitz scaling and um mentions some
like examples of of this anti-realist uh
claim so he says Google Uber Airbnb and
Facebook are the product of a
fundamentally anti-realist enactment of
an interaction with the respective Eco
niches powered by unique and
continuously evolving sets of
capabilities fostering action generated
top-down bottom-up prediction error
minimization to iteratively optimize
their very generative models and implied
recognition posterior probabilities of
beliefs about the actions consequences
these companies redesign while they fly
which is in the words of Silicon Valley
veteran Reed Hoffman equivalent to
throwing yourself off a cliff and
assembling your airplane on the way down
Sullivan 2016. in fact we are more in
control than we resist to believe Blitz
scaling has been integral to the
founding DNA of these super
outperformers they listen to incense
what wants to emerge they are the
enacting designers of their very Eco
Niche for these companies strategy is
rather a matter of ex post sense making
then ex-anti long-term planning it is a
matter of survival
and I just thought that that was maybe a
good example of this anti-realism
um thing that that he was talking about
here
uh do you guys understand
an idea that kind of arose as you were
talking about this is that one
interesting point about Google is that
they're also kind of famous for trying
really hard to do this but failing to
create new products so they've like
created and killed like hundreds of
different new like products that people
genuinely like truly loved even that
were quite Innovative and so it's kind
of interesting of like how you even
think about like
what is trying to emerge and whether
that's best done in like a single
monolithic organization versus in a more
like decentralized distributed way
um so I don't know I this has been like
a tension I've been kind of feeling
throughout the book as well it's kind of
like what is it that this entity is
trying to exist or it needs to exist or
is it something that is more distributed
and decentralized is more appropriate in
certain cases
so having loved and lost several Google
things in the past that have like people
are either
uh yeah Google or Google App Maker like
the low code app developing app
development thing I mean just like tons
of things right having loved and lost I
wonder if this is like epistemic
exploration on the part of Google really
so so if like you're you know I don't
know I feel like people come in and like
I'm gonna build this app and Google
gives them a lot of freedom and they're
like go ahead build the app or build the
platform or build the thing and do the
thing and they build it and it's great
and people love it and then they move on
and do something else and then nobody
steps up to support the love of this
part or what was this person's like
child at Google right so I feel like
maybe that might be a lot of what's
happening but but perhaps in this like
creation and then unsupporting creation
and unsupporting Google is continuously
generating like epistemic knowledge
right it's epistemic foraging of and
learning about the niche and what people
like and what they will use you know it
it like on the grand scheme well I think
it's I think that's true but I'm not
going to make this argument but a lot of
people have made the argument that what
they should have been doing the whole
time is exploiting because like their
home business is just ads and they're
like just like run that until you die
like that's the only thing that matters
like your resources aren't well used
here by like trying to do like all of
these random things
um and so like there is like a
legitimate argument too of like the
limits to which you can explore maybe I
don't know that's probably out of scope
for our discussion today but
um all right Daniel yeah just one short
note the entire discussion of epistemic
and pragmatic value is motivated
motivated by the fact that they're
unified in the free energy functions
that are used to determine perception
cognition and action in an integrated
way so at the very least conversation
can be had about adaptive changes in
these variables at different levels of
the organization
in a different if not better way that's
very integrated with how we think about
the world internally and built upon
Neuroscience in that area as well as
about thinking about the complex
Dynamics and the relational dynamics of
the niche which for information doesn't
exist until you're seeking it out and in
feedback with it and inattention of your
previous data in anticipation of future
data all of these cognitive Dynamics so
the anti-realist take doesn't need to be
someone who doesn't think like a real
world exists or anything like that even
though that's like too deep for this
current discussion it's just a purely
pragmatic approach to thinking about and
modeling these kinds of scenarios
very cool all right what else ah okay so
here we are we got through the preface
that was the preface
um and so getting into part one of the
book uh there's just this small quote
which I'll read the it says reframing
the strategy governance conversation the
evidence suggests that we are in the
midst of an evolutionary punctuation we
are witnessing a mass extinction in the
corporate world in the early Decades of
the 21st century since 2000 52 of the
Fortune 500 companies have either been
acquired merged or have declared
bankruptcy it is estimated that 40 of
the companies in existence today will
shutter their operations in the next 10
years merely following the trends of
change is not enough just like organisms
facing the great oxidation event
organizations need to reinvent the way
they interact with the changing world
and this is a quote from digital
transformation survive and thrive in an
era of mass extinction at 2019 by siebel
all right chapter one thinking born of
curiosity revolt and change all right
here's our abstract Tyler I'm gonna let
you read this one
all right environmental complexity and
velocity have been dominant moderators
and strategy and governance research
the underlying structure of
environmental change is becoming
increasingly distributed and
discontinuous the disciplinating nature
of Information Technology is challenging
the trench business models as well as
the Logics of organizing socialized
top-down strategy processes are rather
anti-clocked unless dynamically and
generatively intertwined in real time
with bottom-up stimuli and data
emanating with field operations in
pursuit of prediction error minimization
neither established Logics of organizing
or prevalent corporate governance models
are a match for wholesale digital
reinvention and continuous strategic
renewal
nice and going on he says
in fact akin to the AI Evolution from a
supervised to a deep learning logic
corporate governance is challenged to
evolve from a supervised and rule-based
best practices Learning System to one of
unsupervised unlearning I.E
self-organization
to survive the firm must be conceived as
one cross hierarchically integrated
inference machine organizing is
generative prediction error minimization
strategy is redefined as top-down
bottom-up predictions processing the
search for knowledge is nourished not
nourished by certainty it is nourished
by a radical absence of certainty
thinking born of curiosity revolt and
change and that's a quote from rovelli
2021.
all right all right Tyler
so uh one of the core premises of the
app the abstract is saying hey the
environmental complexity and velocity
increasing over time and that makes it
more challenging for organizations
um to survive so what he says is
environmental complexity and velocity
have been dominant moderators and
strategy and governance research indeed
the rate of change has not only been
accelerating but the underlying
structure of change has become
increasingly distributed and
discontinuous sense of urgency and heed
full interrelating are critical to
survival in a world that is now commonly
perceived as uh full of surprises and so
yeah this is something just by being on
like the inside of a lot of these
organizations including corporations a
lot of times it's perceived as hey
there's it's a Scary World out there we
just need to get our information better
to kind of understand what's actually
happening so we don't have
um any problems but I think the problem
is that like the world is changing so
much faster than it had been before
where like this kind of Relentless
approach of hey we're just going to get
more we're going to gradually improve
our processes to wash away this
uncertainty that doesn't work as well
anymore and I think this kind of former
approach uh strategy is very much
encapsulated by like Six Sigma design I
don't know if you guys are familiar with
that but it's kind of like a
manufacturing idea of like hey we're
just going to slowly and incrementally
increase the Precision of our techniques
and our processes because these any
instruments you have Cascades across
your whole supply chain and all of your
other processes so we just need to
figure everything out and so everything
will be perfect and we won't have any
issues
um and that may be like somewhat of a
illusion that you can tell yourself if
things aren't changing that quickly and
maybe that'll work for like some
constrained amount of time but in the
modern world it's hard really hard to
have that illusion you have to have a
different mental model of the world
um all right move on to the unless blue
and Daniel had anything no all right um
so the second piece of this is like yes
the world is changing really quickly and
that means that there's going to be more
discontinuities and so he says our
discounting of these are fundamentally a
function of the cost of interacting with
the outer World in form of generating
and testing predictions and so Wix is
not discontinuity it's really about like
this gap between perceiving the world
and saying okay
how are we going to take action how are
we going to update our generative model
accordingly accordingly and
what he's saying is that you know as the
world becomes more complex change is
much faster than ever did before there
are more of these discontinuities but
also the discontinuities are larger
there's just more information to
integrate and so like on one level you
could say like this is really terrifying
world's changing what do we do but he
also sounds this optimistic note of
saying like well yes the modern world
creates more discontinuities but it also
creates more tools for navigating
business continuities and so the first
one he says is well you know is about
distance remediation and
decentralization so it's a lot easier to
aggregate data and process that
information and have backup plans in
case plan a fails you have plans you
know B through Z instead the other
aspect of this is AI and so it's a lot
easier to process bigger and deeper sets
of data and so he's trying to sound this
optimistic note that hey not All Is Lost
there is a way to navigate through this
uncertainty
I just have to say I love this meme
as someone as someone who's like tried
to like organize and restructure my life
probably I don't know 500 000 times at
this point
um like it's like do I just do the work
or do I spend time like agonizing about
how to like document and structure and
like time plan my day into five minute
blocks so like like I invest so much
time in like some method right and then
I'm just like okay well I methodized it
and then I never used the method I just
go back to doing the work so it's it's
like this weird like all this time
analyzing what like or dumping it into
like moderating my efficiency is like
wasting my efficiency
to connect that to the earlier
discussion about the two senses of meta
this time cost associated with strategy
and with consequences in the real world
that time cost can be understood as a
cognitive cost and something internal
that's happening metacognitive how
should I decide how to decide how to
perceive this some of those are
variables and knobs you can understand
and change other ones are really
subliminal and then also that time cost
strategy Nexus of course exists for
organizations and teams and all of these
nested and complex interactions so we
want to use active inference as an
integrative principle because it helps
us connect what's happening on either
side of the Markov blanket which might
be like a data set passed between two
areas of a community or of an
organization understanding how the
emission model and the reception model
work together
yeah to attach that a little more is
that like
you know I was I've been a product
Analyst at uh some like a couple of
different startups and you actually see
this in a real way where like sometimes
you can get an okay answer by just
taking like the like a super like simple
average of a couple different categories
or you could try to do something really
clever and create like an app like you
know an ml model or something over
um to predict something and a lot of
times it's like it doesn't the
predictive power you gain doesn't match
the time cost of that and by the time
you created this really sophisticated
like publishable uh model the world has
fundamentally changed so much that your
model just like doesn't matter anymore
uh and so like you're very like
time-bounded and like how you can even
like use the information you gather and
the results you you glean so for example
if you even if you have like a a
checkout flow and you say oh yeah like
uh with this button the checkout flow is
10 more effective than with this button
well it could it will very likely be the
change in six months the context of that
checkout flow has changed so much that
it's actually just kind of meaningless
information and so like the
time-boundedness of the information you
collect and the perceptions you can form
of that matter a lot
all right
um all right so the inference machine
um so to survive the firm must become
one cross hierarchically integrated
inference machine that continuously
builds predictions which are calling to
be bottom of challenge
um and so I think this very much aligns
with what we talked about before like
agile methodology this kind of Lean
Startup method of you build
see if if it worked you kind of like
integrate those
um those perceptions and learn from it
use that to ideate and something that is
a creative act into the world not
necessarily something that is fully
informed by data
um and then you build and act on it
um and he uses this quote a few times
both in the premise I think he actually
opens the book with this uh he says
there's a Carlo ravelli quote the search
for knowledge is not nourished by
certainty it is nourished by radical
absence of certainty thinking born of
curiosity revolt and change
so this is actually very important
because I've actually encountered this
tension very often in a lot of
organizations where like a lot of
organization is one of the data driven
and they don't actually another way to
say this is this is the best product
advice that was ever given any it was
from CEO of my last companies and said
there's two types of product work
there's art and there's science
and the science work is like you're like
hey like we know this works we know we
can speed up this checkout flow it might
get like incrementally better we kind of
can just keep going on there's like the
exploit path but then there's art which
is really just like not informed by the
data and a lot of times organizations
have trouble with this because it is
truly a creative act and they're not
comfortable taking that leap of faith
and that's really what like you have to
do to do anything uh meaningful and a
lot of people are much more comfortable
in the exploit path which is a lot
easier to sell to your bosses it's a lot
more comfortable and you have to really
like CR like very consciously create a
culture within your firm that like the
explore path is like even okay and
something that can be rewarded
um
all right anything that you guys want to
add here before we on the next slide
all right um so something that I found
of uh something I found that was
interesting with
you know reading this preface and the
first chapter was that like a lot of the
themes are kind of emerging in a less
technical Frameworks and also kind of
like almost like pseudo-spiritual ideas
about business management uh and so this
is like a quote that was from the paper
uh or from the book it says that firms
are called to open up all four channels
of listening listen from what you know
what surprises you from the whole and
what and what you and what you sense
once you emerge the emerging home right
and so if we kind of think about
integrating information across different
levels of the hierarchy like uh Jean was
talking about like you can think about
that from a more like rigorous academic
perspective but there's like a lot of
other books especially that come over
the last five years that are conceiving
the organization
um you know almost like a
pseudo-spiritual lens where it's
conceiving the organization not as like
the extension of the CEO's ego but
really as like this entity that needs to
be nurtured and cultivated and
understood on its own terms one of the
most famous books about this is called
Reinventing organizations and this
reading organizations introduce the idea
of teal organizations these are like
non-hierarchical heterogeneous
organizations
um so in that book he says instead of
trying to predict and control the future
members of the organization are invited
to listen in and understand what the
organization wants to become what
purpose it wants to serve which like on
first reading like that can feel very
like
pseudo-spiritual and kind of like hand
wavy but is actually like a very real
thing that can actually be modeled in a
more rigorous way with activator and so
I think that's really exciting another
way that this has been talked about has
been uh in Brian J Robertson's book
holography holocracy is another similar
to like teal organizations it is a
non-hierarchical form of governance
and so he says each tension human being
sense is a signpost telling us how the
organization could evolve to better
express its purpose
all right anything you guys want to add
that
cool
cool so I don't know anything else that
you guys want to add
um just thanks for being here and going
over this uh stuff with me
um and is there anything else you're
looking forward to or or what's next
I'm really excited awesome oh just
logistically how is the series going to
continue
sure so we'll finish one chapter a week
is the goal
um maybe like we're trying to still work
out the logistics of the holiday but I
think it looks consistent
um so one chapter of the book per week
something about that something like
along those lines and then a discussion
after each like section of the book so
there's part one part two part three
um and we will get in touch with the
author and see maybe if he is willing to
come and discuss some of these ideas
with us or and hopefully we'll have
other
um people that want to participate in
the discussions of the works
Tyler and then I'll give a thought
yeah I mean I think the thing I'm
looking forward to is you know so far
what I've been excited about is that
putting a a concrete framework behind
ideas that have so far been expressed in
very abstract kind of hand wavy terms
across you know different kind of
startup folklore and
um kind of business type businessy books
and so I'm curious as a Next Step about
how it can become a little more like
tangible and practical and like for
someone who is from the perspective like
being in an organization how do you how
would you actually design an
organization to embody pre-energy
governance
um and so I'm really excited to see how
that can become a little more concrete
and clear
cool the part I'm looking forward to is
continuing to explore that explore
exploit dialectic
both of those in the extreme
lead to failure in some way or at least
increase risk and so this frames our
strategizing as being like in some sort
of landscape with explore and exploit
which of course is really complex with
these nested organizations
and then you brought in the Art and
Science or um science and engineering or
just art and communication or whatever
other dialectic and then even within an
artist's day there's realities like
accounting and the mixing of the paint
and even the prompt engineering for
someone who's using those kinds of
artistic forms so it lets there be sort
of a light
and adaptive quote explore exploit
scenario happening within the context of
something that's a lot more meaningful
which is the integration of like art
science personal meaning Collective
meaning and so on without denying that
those kinds of explore exploit
attentional and strategic Dynamics must
happen also
cool well thanks for participating guys
and um we'll see you next time
bye y'all